all right Laura
Laura where you from originally where'd
you grow up um I was born in New Jersey
but I grew up in New England
Massachusetts
tell me about how your childhood
what it was pretty typical I mean you
know Mom Dad parents are still together
little brother golden retriever kind of
like your white picket fence kind of
upbringing but it was my dad who got me
interested in this stuff he started
reading Nancy Drew to me he's a little
girl and I would always fantasize that I
would be Nancy Drew one day and like
solving these Mysteries and it kind of
led into True Crime and then I started
reading all the profiler books this is
like middle school high school and then
it just transpired from there so serial
killers are typically your that's
something that you study yes and you you
do interviews with these guys yeah I've
interviewed over 50 serial killers and
for what application what what purpose
I'm actually conducting the largest
Collective study on serial killers
currently
um for the last 10 years
I've even beaten the FBI for the largest
Collective study
what kind of guys have you interviewed
you've done some well-known ones
very well known yeah and it ranges we
have a missionary killer Visionary
killer
um lust thrill you name it every type of
serial killer is part of this study any
names that we recognize
um yes so I can say the ones that have
died
um Roy Norris who is one of the toolbox
Killers he did participate in the study
uh let's see who else is there uh Robert
Bobby long he recently died he's one of
the other Killers who else
Gregory Miley so he's part of the
freeway Killers with William Bonin
these are all us-based yes yes
so tell me how these
men they're all men yes
um they're all men that's an interesting
Yeah question right there
um what what kind of things are you
learning about these kind of
individuals you know it's really
fascinating because each one is so
different from one another but then
there's these common similarities as
well I'm seeing like the correlations in
between them
um I was just telling a friend every
time I go into the prison they all ask
me for a Coke and a Hershey's dark
chocolate
every single one which I thought is so
strange really yeah you seem like a
pretty straightforward very normal woman
but yes and you're married not married
not married okay
tell me how this affects your your life
personally
well it's pretty like all consuming you
know because it's every day all day I
mean they call my phone probably from
starting at 7am until nine PM sometimes
12 a.m so is that something you you
enjoy you tolerate you you dislike I
mean you know I love what I do but you
know it's any kind of job you have those
days where you're just like exhausted
from it
um so it's just like a typical job like
even if you love what you do you still
have those moments of just burnout
tell me some of your stories you must
have some interesting ones oh I have so
many
um
trying to think of a really good one for
you
you'll go into the prisons yeah going
into the prisons
so the first time I was ever
um well my first prison experience ever
was San Quentin's death row and I was
going into interview Lawrence Whitaker
who's the most sadistic serial killer in
the nation and I was 26. so that was
um a really wild experience you're there
with guards or just one-on-one you're
one-on-one you're locked in a cage with
them uncuffed but there are guards
outside that you can wave down if you
need them
what do you think their basic motivation
I mean what why are these men so extreme
in there
you know um 80 is an underlying sexual
motivation
um and then I see thrill on top of the
sexual motivation a lot
pretty much all of them these crimes are
not just murders they're they're sex
crimes yes typically there's rape
present or
some type of sexual act with the serial
killer is it because they they don't
have
females available to them
no I mean there are some like a lot of
serial killers are married have
girlfriends
um but the kind of sex they're looking
for
um
you know is deviant they won't share
that with a loved one partner type of
thing so they go out and get a surrogate
um to do these deviant sexual acts with
but then you know that's one thing but
then murderers all another yes yes
what did you learn about their
childhoods
um with their childhoods I see a lot of
trauma
um a lot of neglect
with a lot of them
um last week I was talking to two serial
killers and one of them was abandoned at
18 months
um and he survived by um with these dogs
in a back alley at 18 months for like
six months he was abandoned and somehow
survived and he wasn't able to talk
until he was six he was sharing that
experience with me another one was
telling me how his mother shot him up
with Heroin at 13 years old
hope for these
these men
um any Rehabilitation Rehabilitation
that's a
that's a great question
could they be rehabilitated I think
we're you know working towards that
we're striving towards that
um
you know over in Europe they're kind of
light years ahead of us
um what ways
well they just have um lower crime rates
they don't have the serial killing like
we do here
um yeah and they have more just proven
methods we are just starting to actually
go over to Europe to study and Implement
their systems over here Oregon's doing
it California is working to do it as
well
but why do you think the U.S is so off
track I mean we have the mass shootings
we have serial killers yeah you know um
I think a big part of it is Hollywood
you know we have violence and the true
crime and shoved down our faces every
jump down our throats every day then we
have um it's our cultural aspects over
in Europe you know everything's more
about family and togetherness and
Community we don't have a sense of that
here that's kind of like missing from
our society
yeah that's sad it's a
it's getting worse it seems it yeah yeah
when you don't have a sense of community
you really don't it doesn't feel like
you have a support system
are those the basic common denominators
between all these men that you've
interviewed
yeah
and it seems like our justice system is
well obviously very broken
and then our prison system is just to
make money pretty much and that's also
broken and we're not geared toward
Rehabilitation so we're pretty much just
letting them back out into society to
reoffend or we're not focusing on the
core issue and problem when someone
kills like the way the men you're
interviewing do
there's a there's even a chance that
they can get out
yeah really yeah
um do you think they'd be locked away
forever you would think
um no I know a lot of murderers who have
gotten out I know bitticker and Nora so
I studied extensively they were let out
after violent rapes and an attempted
murder
um and they went on to kill five teenage
girls
after they got out yeah
therapy is the answer
yeah castration what do you think well
they are doing medical castration over
in Europe for the sex offenders they're
given a choice to either stay in prison
or you know you can get let out back
into society but you know medical
castration and does that is that
effective it is effective it is um
that's what I always thought like with
some of the sex offenders that yeah I've
interviewed it's like why would why
would
castration not be the answer to this
well it has to be a choice for them
which is given to them over in Europe
um I work with my partner Dr John White
he's a forensic psychologist out of
Stockton University and he actually
counsels sex offenders that have been
let out of prison and he does medical
castration so they come in every three
months and he injects them with the shot
every three months
and that works yeah it works yep
takes away the libido yeah which yes
I've heard people say that it's it's not
uh sexual gratification that they're
seeking it's it's the the violence that
they enjoy it is it's the power and
control that they get over a victim is
what they're seeking and what they want
and you'll see that play out in areas of
their personality when a rapist is in
prison you'll notice them snitching a
lot on just Guys near them because they
still want that power that control
they're taking away their libido doesn't
it does or does not solve the problem it
solves a problem of rape yeah but that
need for the power and control will
still be present
so back to your interesting stories
tell me something of some of your
interactions that you've had
many
I mean every
every experience every time I go into a
prison
each one is like um
memorable like my rule of thumb is I
don't leave the prison without an
unknown piece of information so I have
to walk out with something I didn't know
before I've learned something and every
single time I have walked out you know
learning something uh finding out
something about their case or you know
their psychopathy I always walk out with
something
um
I found dark humor to be like almost
like a secret weapon
I remember once I was mentioning an uh
episode of Always Sunny in Philadelphia
and I was laughing thinking about the
episode and the offender thought I was
like laughing along with him
and he actually gave a big confession to
his case
um so that's the biggest thing I do is I
try to get them comfortable and at ease
to talk about these crimes and this
deviant sexual acts and stuff because it
can be you know really embarrassing
especially for them so I try to make
them as comfortable as possible and
that's how I extract the most
information from them
I assume there's all kinds of different
personalities some of them are probably
Charming
yeah
psychopaths are known to be very
charming and they love bomb you so yeah
I encounter those types
um but once you really know psychopathy
like you can actually gauge it in all
their moves the gas lighting that'll
come next
um yeah they pretty much stick to a
script almost
what is it about you that that Drew you
to this you think
well
um you know my dad reading Nancy Drew is
really what got me into this and it's
you know it's when people ask me what
got me into this it's kind of like
asking me why is the sky blue it's kind
of like a knowing like a mission like
I've just known this is what I was meant
to do in the worlds I've just always
known
um it's not even really like consensual
Choice I've just this is what I was here
to do is the adrenaline part of the
attraction for you
um adrenaline you definitely get a huge
Adrenaline Rush
um
yeah but I wouldn't say that's part of
the factor into it um but yeah it is
very very intense so you definitely get
a rush from it
they have both parents in some cases
yeah some of these guys actually had
very normal upbringings as well and
those are the ones I like to look into
um you know because that doesn't really
make sense you know they have the white
picket fence family and there's no
trauma there's no like you can't find
what's causing this from childhood so
you really want to that's when I dig
more into their psychopathy themselves
more so than you know the situations of
their childhood
and some of these guys have been
executed I'm sure right
yes yes
um Robert Bobby Long who I mentioned for
the study he was executed
and it was during the time he was taking
the study
your study is going to turn into what a
book or yeah it'll be a book well um we
have um already have a couple uh offers
uh University publishers
so it'll be out for the public that's
great yeah
it's very fascinating
I'm sure some of the men have taken a
viking to you
yeah they um they get attached very
quick
um in prison you know they're in a
non-stimulated environment so it's very
anything to the outside world that
they'll latch onto and get attached to
nothing that has ever happened no no
they know what they can and can't get
away with in that situation I guess
yeah they definitely do
um well most of their prairie probably
pretty intelligent
the ones um you know the IQ average uh
it ranges with serial killers for the IQ
but the ones I've worked with out of San
Quentin um are uh genius level
and what it's just a
they're Psychopaths yeah yeah doesn't
matter how smart you are if you're a
psychopath you're still a psychopath
yeah yeah
and there's usually a couple more
disorders on top of being on top of
being a psychopath or psychopathy I have
one with explosive personality disorder
and he can get angered or triggered at
anything at any moment in time
um yeah it ranges it's usually not just
one disorder is present there'll usually
be a few and there were there clues of
this kind of extreme Behavior when they
were children
yeah if you dig into their childhood
you'll see you know fights maybe great
starting at grade school
um I talk to them a lot about like
sexual images they first saw as a child
and a lot of the sexual images they
first saw their first experience was of
like a woman in bondage or something of
violent nature
pouring a part of this
problem I think porn yeah it's
definitely a factor I think Ted Bundy
was the first one who pointed it out
about the porn but I've noticed that
especially especially recently too um
because now they have a ton of access to
all types of porn on the internet and
any type of violent porn they want
there's a couple generations of young
men that are growing up with it yes
yes which they never have been before
yeah I mean I guess there were magazines
but now now it's like
yeah on everyone's phone
um all of them have told me they read
those True Detective magazines back in
the day because it all had like violent
images of women kind of like in lingerie
you know tied up or something and that
was kind of like their porn magazine
back in the day
and now they can just you know go right
on the internet and get whatever they
want
and Are there women who are attracted to
these men that have like you know
um pen pal relationships
yeah I've every time I'm standing in
lines at the prison I'll meet like the
wives and the mothers or girlfriends
like yeah that's usually who I encounter
um
walking the line that's saying
I think those would be interesting
interviews as well yeah I've actually
stayed with a death row inmate's wife
um I had to go up to San Quentin for an
extended period of time almost like two
months and uh yeah I stayed with her
and it was a very cool experience I also
got a chance to stay with one of the
mothers of a death Pro in me
it must have been fascinating it was
fascinating because I got to you know
meet both parents I got to look through
the scrapbooks home videos I mean it was
like
a forensic psychologist's dream to be
able to like kind of have that access
and peek into their life
what was she like
lovely I mean they were both parents
were lovely couldn't be kinder sweeter
yeah they're just confused about what
what happened to their son yeah
and what do you think it is is it
something that they were
something that they something that
happened to them something they were
exposed to or is it something in their
DNA or something
in their brain chemistry well they say
you know for psychopaths it's it's uh
genes
um and then sociopaths it's from you
know more nurture the environment
um so you know both can play a factor
and I really believe it's a combination
of both
who would you describe as like one of
the most interesting
men that you've interviewed they're all
they're also interesting in their own
way
um
I would say uh Lawrence bitticker for
his sadism and just his whole
psychopathy and the way he viewed things
was so fascinating I spoke with the FBI
and they said the same thing they just
love to dig into his psychopathy
I would say for Wayne Adam Ford is so
fascinating because he is one that
actually turned himself in which is so
incredibly rare so
that has been like an experience to have
a serial killer who's actually turned
himself in he knew he couldn't stop and
he did the right thing
um unfortunately four lives were lost
though
um
yeah those two are really fascinating
um and then
I think of like another really I have
one who's severely mentally ill so I
kind of get to see a glimpse into the
ones that like aren't even really aware
of what they're doing I've had that
experience
are there some that are
have some self-awareness and remorse for
what they've done
oh yeah they definitely they're very um
very aware
and they're very introspective
contrary to popular belief they've been
very introspective when I talk to them
about their crimes
is there a part of them just like oh my
God I'm a terrible
thing for you know for doing this yeah
they'll have like those those
realization moments
um with bitticker you know I was with
him on his deathbed and that's when it
really hit him
um you know and I talked to this FBI
profiler who is he um was getting me
ready for the final round of interviews
with him and he said the death row death
confessions are it's a very very intense
um as they're dying
um it's like no other interview so he
kind of like prepped me for it and it
was exactly as he described it because
you know they're facing now death and
they're thinking where am I going next
and that realization of what they have
done is starting to hit them
are there some that are in denial of you
know saying they're still innocent you
know that they didn't do these crimes
yeah so there are some that play games
like that yeah
I have um two at San Quentin right now
playing that game
um
with those what I like to do is I call
them like onions you kind of just have
to slowly peel them and peel them how
many times do you meet with these men
um it's the last couple years a lot
um it's kind of like because of the
research and every all the work I've
been doing they've been flying me up a
lot
um so but I would say every couple
months I'm up there
and so one one of these serial killers
you'll interview how many times
um
I'm up to like thousands upon thousands
of hours now huh yeah
and each time you
like peel an onion basically literally
peel an onion yeah
you you know you go deeper and deeper
the more trust and the Rapport that you
build with them
um the more you're going to get
the more they're going to confide in you
and trust you and start talking what
qualities do you see in common with all
of these men I mean did they have
friends socially
it's
um mixed some were very popular and then
the other half were kind of loners I
would say I would see loners way more
with these men
druggies
a lot of drug use yeah
probably the most common is stimulants
what other qualities do you see
common among them common within them
um let's see
Lone Wolf
um the neglect from childhood the
biggest one I would say definitely is
there's a breakdown between the mother
and son relationship
that's the biggest one
um
you know mommy issues
it's it's really true there's some that
Primal bond between mother and son was
disrupted
it's traded down from one generation to
the next and you kind of see that with
the crimes when you see like the
mutilation of female sexual organs or in
the killing of women
um this is typically from anger towards
the mother and typically from the first
rejection of a woman
so just recently it took me about four
years to break down Lawrence Whitaker
and to get the confessions he finally
told me where he buried the evidence and
where the two missing girls are as well
as some other stuff that's going to be
coming to light soon
but just recently I got one
I got it down to two weeks my goal is to
get down the confession to five hours
that's how long I spend in the cage
about five to six hours with them
so that's my goal but I'm down to two
weeks now
and you know my main goal now is you
know I'm doing the study there but since
I've been in San Quentin and the other
prisons so much I'm finding out about
you know all these missing bodies and
victims that have never been recovered
you know once they are sentenced you
know to life in prison or death
um they don't search for these victims
and their families really have no
closure no justice no nothing they can't
even have a funeral so now it's kind of
like my mission to actually help uncover
the missing victims and find where they
are return them to their family so they
can finally have a funeral
um
right after my 27th birthday
um my cousin who is like my older
brother we were like Irish twins he uh
murdered my best friend and her father
so I think
that motivated the work that I do even
more and I remember at her funeral
thinking
you know at least I had one Solace which
was that I was able to bury her and I
think about the families out there that
don't have that
so your cousin
murdered someone yes do you think that
has anything to do with your
the direction your career took no I mean
it started from when I ever since I
could remember really but it definitely
played
um a factor in motivation
yeah
because now it's just so deeply personal
to me
they're from big cities small towns
small towns mostly small towns yeah
um fun fact is Los Angeles is like the
hub for serial killers
has it has had the most serial killers
within the city really
yeah
Hollywood kind of like you know attracts
people from all over the world and you
have people from out of state it's just
like a perfect feeding ground for these
types of predators people that don't fit
in socially right figure they'll come to
California and start over right exactly
and you know Skid Row is where they go
to hunt mainly
yeah I've heard so many stories down
there of
women over the decades who have just
been thrown in trash in dumpsters oh
yeah yeah chopped up and things like
that
yeah I think it still goes on to this
day oh it definitely does yeah
yeah how many how many of the gentlemen
that should be in prison for these kind
of crimes do you think there are out
there in the world
that are not I think there's a lot more
than a lot of the experts estimate I
think they estimate like 2 000 but I
believe there's a lot more you know
those estimates
um those those numbers they they are
estimating on our bodies that are found
we're not calculating you know the ones
up in the mountains that are high you
know know how to get rid of a body so
the true number is really unknown
was it difficult to get access to to
these gentlemen when you started
uh it wasn't that difficult you know I
wrote an intro letter of who I am and
what I was doing and then you know you
send in the form to be a date well they
have to sign off on it once they sign
off they do a FBI check on you and then
you get approved and you can go in so
the prisoner has to sign off first
prisoner has to sign off you have to
agree to it yes which I would think they
would be happy to do
you would think that actually I've
gotten a lot of rejections and Lawrence
bitticker the one I did the case on he
actually never sent me a visiting form I
was able to get one though through
another serial killer within the prison
and just networking
so even if they deny me I still get the
visiting form send it in and I just show
up
but it's a gamble if they're going to
come down from their cells or not the
day of
what are you hoping to achieve by
the Gathering research Gathering all
this information you know I really want
to
well the premise of the whole study
itself is to help clinicians in forensic
settings for you know forensic evalves
and testing them when they're coming
into County I'm hoping we can start you
know seeing a thought pattern or you
know behaviors early on for prevention
of these uh more violent crimes that's
the main goal of this study we want to
do a part two that helps catch offenders
quicker and that'll be geared towards
law enforcement so yeah the overall is
to work towards prevention of this and
if we can develop you know therapeutic
mess you know therapeutic methods as
well
and change some of the laws maybe yes
the laws need to be changed so uh badly
especially for victims you know you
wouldn't believe um
how little resources there are for
victims out there victims of stalking
um sexual assault it's it's mind-blowing
what do you think it is that
it's almost exclusively men that are
doing this
um well you know men are more sexually
motivated just in general
um so I think that definitely is just a
factor of it
um but it's not that women are just like
innocent you know when there is a female
serial killer they can kill up in the
hundreds
um I think they're just
sneakier about it if you look at some of
the historic cases and people don't
suspect women as much as they suspect
men
yeah women have a reputation as being
gentler Kinder right right more
good-hearted yeah
if you look at Lizzie Borden which was
like the first female in America put on
trial she got acquitted because no one
could believe a woman could ever
do such a gruesome murder
do you find being around these kind of
men and doing this kind of
research has affected your personal life
um yes yes and no I would say dark stuff
you're studying it is
um
I think it's a lot for my friends and
for like any
um intimate relationship I have you know
because they're it's just non-stop all
time consuming and I'm just such a
workaholic so I would say it definitely
like gets in the way of like you know
going out or just spending time with
them so it definitely plays into that
and they'll get annoyed at the phone
just ringing off the hook constantly and
just me being absorbed in this world
getting phone calls from serial killers
yes yeah
yeah
what's the creepiest thing you've seen
in your interviews or in these men um
probably
probably on San Quentin's death
serial killers body swapping or trying
to body swap
meaning like you take those two bodies
say they were yours so I can get rid of
them
but that's it's actually common to see
on San Quinn's death row
so the murdering other prisoners
no they're saying like I don't want to
take these two bodies I have an appeal
coming up will you take them for me Oh
you mean
say you didn't oh oh oh I see yeah
because they're all on top of each other
oh so is somebody
is already like in there for Life yeah
it doesn't matter if he's got three more
yeah
doesn't matter so yeah I'll see the body
swapping a lot talk of it just out in
the open
wow
murder is like um
an interaction
at San Quentin it's just a transaction
to them is the way they speak about it
but what's most important to these men
what are they looking for they're
looking for power
yeah probably one of the biggest things
is power
yeah
contrary to
um belief they're not looking for fame
not the typical one they actually hate
you know any cameras or do books
anything they don't want the attention
um that's a big misconception everybody
has uh that is how they are portrayed in
Hollywood
um but it's not a true
Laura what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned from all
these studies
God
um
you know I've
what's the most important thing
you know I've learned about life
honestly I don't take a second for
granted I've really seen how short and
precious life is and you know every day
I wake up and I think you know I'm not
being held captive in a basement you
know I'm breathing you know and I'm
thankful for that
because what I've you know encountered
and what I've seen so it's really given
me a newfound appreciation of life
tell me one of your stories of some of
the behaviors of some of these guys that
you've interviewed well when I sat down
with uh Lawrence bitticker I think it
was the second time
he his victims were blonde hair blue
eyes so he said to me that a therapist
at San Quentin will not sit with him
because she has blonde hair blue eyes
and he looked at me and he's like but
you're in a cage with me
and he had this like smirk on his face
and he's like how do you feel being in a
cage with me
and it was like almost a sadistic power
play
and I was like how should I feel should
I be scared are you gonna do something
to me
and he just like sat back kind of like
smirking kind of like very Hannibal
Lecter
and he's like no
it's very calm but with the smirk still
on his face
so another story I have this actually
just recently happened
I was in the prison and uh I was in the
cage with the serial killer and he he
says to me um
he says to me
um some men like to dismantle cars some
men like to dismantle women
and I like turned to get the CEO because
I needed him for something and he was
asleep and I started knocking and trying
to call the attention but he was a
yeah he was asleep for five minutes and
I was just sitting there in the cage and
and I remember just looking at the
serial killers going okay well
you know I know you could kill me in
this moment he just laughed and he's
like I'm not going to
that's probably the creepiest that was
the one that really freaked me out yeah
that would screwed me out it was um
because there was an FBI profiler and he
pushed the panic button once they didn't
come and it reminded me just like that
moment and the serial killer said
something to him about you know I could
take your head off right now
but they just like kind of just say it
and smile
and you're just like okay are they
generally sad men
well if I'd say some but no not
typically
I wouldn't say that
um
a lot of them adapt very well to prison
life yeah you would think though
carrying this weight of what they've
done
would wear on them eventually you would
think but again you're talking about
Psychopaths
um I always ask them how do they feel
you know after they say anything if
they're talking about the crimes well
how did you feel how did you feel
this is a tactic to get them to express
like what emotions they were going
through and you'll see there's none
when you start asking that question and
there are means of killing their victims
is like knives guns strangling what
um I think the number one way I see is
uh yeah strangling
um but yeah it ranges too guns knives
um torture with tools a lot of the time
yeah
and serial killing is a whole nother
thing rather than just somebody who
murdered somebody once over in a fight
or something like that right right
yeah no serial killing is almost an
addiction to these guys
once they have you know
once they've done it the first time
it doesn't stop
is it the adrenaline
yeah a lot of them report about the
adrenaline and the fact they're getting
away with it that high from getting away
with murder
is there an urge to
confess
no
no there's that's very very rare like I
said Wayne Adam Ford is the only one
that's ever you know turned himself in
that I've interviewed and that is
exceptionally rare
do you develop friendships with some of
them
yeah I mean some of them I have a
10-year rapport with
yeah
and in those moments like those scary
moments it really does save your life
I mean just the fact that you're being
like some form of friend
it becomes very valuable to them they've
never had that before I assume no not a
lot of them not like a really
um
true friendship
no
yeah it's um it's fascinating how you
know people can be abused and go through
such horrific childhood trauma and
some end up serial killers and others
can go on to help people
what do you think the difference is
I think there's a lot of dispects um
that sends one person a positive
direction another one in a very negative
I think it's a person's like I would say
it's it's genetics is a little bit of a
factor in their mindset too
uh if they're you know if someone's
mentally strong you'll typically see
them going more towards helping serial
killers have very poor coping skills
obviously so
yeah
all right Laura thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah
yeah I wish you lots of luck with your
reviews thank you so much thank you